nouveau numéro de reporter plus le
magazine de grands reportage long format
de France 24 les voitures électriques
nous apparaissent désormais comme la
panacée pour lutter contre les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre et le
réchauffement climatique mais c'est
oublier un peu vite que les batteries
qui les animent ne sont pas sans impact
sur l'environnement prenons le cobalt
par exemple qui rentre dans la
composition bon nombre de batteries
direction la République démocratique du
Congo qui est au cobalt ce que l'Arabie
Saoudite est au pétrole une sorte
d'eldorado pour les industries minières
des compagnies internationales y
exploitent intensivement dans des mines
gigantesques le précieux minerai mais
cela entraîne une pollution des sols et
des eaux les populations locales sont
durement impactées c'est une enquête de
Quentin noirfalys et arnozeïtmans pour
France 24
[Musique]
nous avons peur des
voies
[Musique]
en République démocratique du Congo des
milliers de citoyens sont devenus les
chevilles ouvrières d'une révolution en
marche il creuse pour trouver un minerai
que le marché mondial s'arrache
le cobalt
à l'autre bout du monde grâce à ce métal
nécessaire aux batteries l'industrie
construit assemble et commercialise les
voitures électriques
dans la course contre le changement
climatique le cobalt est une des clés
pour rouler sans polluer
mais à quel prix
[Musique]
en Europe les voitures et le transport
routier sont responsables d'un quart des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
à partir de 2035 la vente de véhicules à
combustion sera interdite au sein de
l'Union européenne
une décision qui a fait toute la chaîne
de production du secteur
a investi au total 1,2 milliards d'euros
sur ce site
et en particulier sur les six
formidables voitures que nous avons
lancé ici
tout a été remanié et nous sommes à
présent sur du 100% électrique nous
construisons ici 100% de voitures
électriques
en Europe la majorité des batteries
reposent sur la technologie NMC nickel
manganèse cobalt qui permettent aux
véhicules de rouler environ 400 km sur
une seule charge en plus du lithium de
manganèse et de nickel ces batteries
contiennent environ 10 kg d'un métal qui
leur confère leur longévité et leur
sécurité le cobalt
o
sa grande autonomie
c'est l'élément de sécurité vous en
mettez un tout petit peu dans votre
batterie pour vous assurer qu'elle ne va
pas prendre feu que ces cellules
resteront stables même dans des
conditions extrêmes
l'essentiel du cobalt est extrait en
République démocratique du Congo
en fait il n'existe pas vraiment
d'autres endroits au monde où le cobalt
possède les mêmes qualités la même
minéralogie il n'y a pas d'autre pays au
monde qui puisse se prévaloir de la même
qualité et des mêmes réserves de
minerais
c'est quasiment l'Arabie Saoudite du
cobalt
[Musique]
o le Congo est une terre bénie ou
maudite tout dépend de la manière de
voir les choses il possède une richesse
géologique et minérale extraordinaire
[Musique]
toujours été un endroit stratégique que
ce soit au 19e siècle avec le caoutchouc
au milieu du 20e siècle avec l'uranium
aujourd'hui avec ces minerais
indispensables à la réalisation des
objectifs que la communauté
internationale a adopté
sur le fait que nous devons atteindre la
neutralité carbone dans le monde et que
cela nécessite de passer au véhicules
électriques aux énergies renouvelables
tout cela exige des minerais
stratégiques provenant du Congo et l'un
des plus essentiels
du cobalt nous sommes au cœur de la
Cooper belt la ceinture de cuivre qui
court sous le Congo et la Zambie voisine
un paysage sculpté par un siècle
d'exploitation minière
c'est ici dans la province du loup Alaba
et du Haut Katanga que se trouve la
plupart des gisements de cuivre et de
cobalt
des entreprises étrangères exploitent
ces immenses richesses
sur les 19 mines industriels de cuivre
et de cobalt 15 sont détenus par des
sociétés chinoises
elles se partagent cette manne avec le
géant suisse Glenn qui détient deux
démines les plus productives au monde ou
encore avec la société région groupe
par camion jusqu'en Afrique du Sud
il est chargé sur des bateaux à Durban
et prend ensuite la direction de la
Chine où il est transformé en produits
chimiques pour les batteries
à partir de là il entre dans la chaîne
d'approvisionnement
à l'heure actuelle la demande mondiale
de cobalt avoisine les 140 150 000
tonnes
on s'attend à ce qu'elle atteigne 250
000 tonnes dans les 5 ans
un nombre considérable de nouveaux
acheteurs va arriver sur le marché et il
va falloir les satisfaire
le cobalt peut aller au-delà de 70 000
dollars la tonne sur le marché mondial
qui coexiste dans les gisements de
cuivre il a aiguisé l'appétit des
sociétés minières depuis l'explosion du
marché des batteries il y a 10 ans
celle-ci ne cesse de grignoter des
terres au grand dam des habitants dont
la plupart vivent avec moins de 2
dollars par jour
nous les populations qui vivons à côté
de l'exploitation minière je crois que
vous avez circuler la vie d'écologie
vous avez vu que il y a pas d'école il y
a pas des hôpitaux il y a pas de route
les gens n'ont pas accès à l'eau potable
et ceux qui ont accès à l'eau ce n'est
pas l'eau potable c'est ce sont de l'eau
c'est de l'eau ou on déverse les acides
et même la nature a fait que certains
villages ont l'air cours d'eau mais ce
sont des cours d'eau déjà pour lui et
donc l'activité minière vient rendre est
entré plutôt d'appauvrir la population
plutôt que d'améliorer les conditions de
vie des populations
des droits humains
[Musique]
du marché des batteries sur la
population
là ce sont les installations de la
sigomie mais vous voyez déjà l'impact
parce que de l'autre côté ouais les
engins ce sont les camions qui sont en
train de décharger les je les appelle
les déchets parce que ce sont les
stériles de la mine ici ainsi
constituent les montagnes il y a 5 ans
ces montants là n'existaient pas
d'accord et pendant la saison 16 comme
ça c'est à dire c'est de la poussière
qui va quitter ce rejet là vers de ses
côtés et quand vous regardez les les
plantes qui sont autour de nous c'est
vraiment une couche de poussière
dans cette zone ici les gens ne
cultivent presque plus est-ce que vous
pensez que ça ça doit être lié aux
poussières qui sont tes mises à partir
de de remblais qui sont là il y a la
poussière mais il y a aussi l'eau la
qualité de l'eau de la rivière en face
de nous partout
les mines industriels du loup là-bas et
du Haut Katanga produisent 80% du cobalt
congolais
les 20% restants proviennent des mines
artisanales
sous les Bach orange des creuseurs
travaillent au fond des puits et de
tunnels de plusieurs dizaines de mètres
de profondeur
Donatien villa est l'un de ses creuseurs
artisanaux
comme lui ils sont 150000 dans la région
venus des quatre coins du pays pour fuir
la misère et arracher leur part du
gâteau minier
réclamaient
[Musique]
un paysage
voilà c'est ça
au continent
[Musique]
meurent dans des éboulements et des
inondations de galeries
mais des milliers de familles dépendent
des miettes de cobalt que l'État et
l'industrie leur permettent d'exploiter
sur des terres qui leur appartiennent
un moyen d'acheter la paix sociale
[Applaudissements]
depuis 20 ans le gouvernement tente
d'organiser ce secteur en zone
d'exploitation légale la loi les oblige
désormais à rejoindre des coopératives
mais ces structures sont en fait très
hiérarchisées et les creuseurs n'ont pas
de part ni de voie au chapitre quand il
s'agit de la gestion de leur mine
la
productions
ça pèse 20 kg avec les Chinois
et vont casser ils vont tricher les
balances pour mettre 10 kg les 20 à 10
mais normalement c'est 20 kg
dans les comptoirs d'achat les creuseurs
vendent principalement à des acheteurs
chinois des entrepreneurs indépendants
qui se sont rués vers le Congo
ils effectuent une première
transformation du minerai avant de
l'exporter vers les fonderies
[Musique]
le plus frappante c'était de voir
comment la ville avait été construite
autour de l'exploitation minière
autour et au-dessus des gisements
j'avais vraiment le sentiment très très
fort que les gens qui vivent là devaient
profiter de ses richesses qui font la
fortune des sociétés chinoises
européennes américaines
de creuse
les creuseurs risquent leur vie et leur
santé pour remonter le minerai
et en plus très peu perçoivent une
rémunération juste pour leur travail ils
sont exploités financièrement
nous avons constaté que des enfants
parfois de 7 ou 8 ans travaillaient
également dans ses mines
aucun parent ne veut que ses enfants
travaillent aucun enfant de 7 ans ne
souhaite pas c'est toute sa journée
après être entré illégalement sur un
site à ramasser des pierres dans le sol
avec en plus le risque d'être battu ou
volé personne ne désire ça s'ils le font
c'est que les circonstances les y
obligent
[Applaudissements]
en 2016 Amnesty International publie un
rapport qui fait trembler l'industrie
automobile
l'ONG reproche aux entreprises qui
produisent des batteries d'utiliser du
COBAL tantacé par des violations des
droits humains comme le recours au
travail des enfants dans les mines
artisanales
[Musique]
quelle société quelles entreprises
technologiques les fabricants de
téléphone et d'ordinateurs portables
utilisent ce cobalt pour leur batterie
que font-ils et que savent-ils de cette
chaîne d'approvisionnement et des
conditions d'extraction
cette étude qui établit le lien entre le
travail des enfants
les exploitations des mines artisanales
l'industrie du cobalt
qui lit ses mines à ses grandes marques
a eu un retentissement énorme dans les
médias
bien plus qu'espérer
aucune marque aucun constructeur
automobile ou tout autre utilisateur
final de cobalt ne veut être étiqueté
comme tirant profit du travail des
enfants c'est de la très mauvaise
publicité
sa nuit à la valeur de l'action en
Bourse c'est injuste à et les
consommateurs n'aiment pas ça
vous indiffère que ce n'est pas votre
problème que vous ne vous intéressez
qu'à vous vous êtes quand même contre
le business
le travail des enfants n'est pas le seul
problème des constructeurs automobiles
leur passage à l'électrique leur a fait
découvrir leur immense dépendance au
cobalt congolais et aux cellules de
Patrick Le contiennent essentiellement
fabriquées en Asie pour développer une
filière batterie l'Europe met alors en
place en 2017 un grand projet industriel
continue de produire les voitures les
meilleures et les plus durables qui
soient
et ce ne sera pas possible si vous
importez des batteries d'un pays sans
traçabilités
européenne pour les batteries cela nous
permet de rattraper la Chine de manière
incroyable
et ce n'est pas bon uniquement pour
l'Europe et pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique il y a aussi
des avantages très clairs pour les
citoyens grâce à la création de nouveaux
emplois grâce à de nouvelles
possibilités d'investissement et à
l'assurance que tout sera fait de
manière 100% durable
l'Europe n'assurait que 3% de la
production mondiale de batterie pour
rattraper son retard elle prévoit de
construire une trentaine de giga usine
d'ici 2035 et ainsi produire 25% de
l'offre mondiale
en Suède des hectares de forêts ont
laissé place à cette nouvelle
technologie
[Musique]
le Suédois northwalt installe une giga
usine première du genre pour un groupe
européen qui ambitionne de concurrencer
les producteurs asiatiques
[Musique]
Carlson suédois et Paolo en italien
ils se sont rencontrés alors qu'ils
travaillaient ces teslave comme ils sont
européens ils se sont tout naturellement
tournés vers l'Europe un continent où
son produit près de 20 millions de
véhicules par an
il y a entre 13 et 14 millions de gens
qui travaillent dans ce secteur et si
vous estimez que tous ces véhicules vont
devenir électriques
ne pas avoir une industrie locale de la
batterie place l'Europe dans une
position très délicate
ils sont donc revenus en Europe pour
fonder North volts fin 2016
automobile sont entrés dans ce projet
dès les débuts BMW a été le premier en
Volkswagen est à la fois un gros client
et un investisseur tendances volts
récemment nous avons annoncé la création
d'une Joyce
afin de construire une autre giga usine
en quête de souveraineté l'Europe
encourage la multiplication des projets
miniers afin d'alimenter les nouvelles
usines de batterie
pour le cobalt c'est en Suède en Norvège
et surtout en Finlande que des réserves
ont été identifiées
deux mines de nickel et de cobalt sont
actuellement actifs dans ce pays cette
autre projet sont en développement
ventant ces dizaines de gisements de
minerais pour batterie la Finlande a
ouvert dimanche portions de cette aire à
l'exploration minière
à 300 km du cercle polaire la société
terrafamée a relancé la production de
l'ancienne mine de sot camo fermé en
2012 après une fuite d'eau toxique dans
les lacs et les rivières de la région
c'est l'état finlandais qui pilotera
famille aux côtés de trafiquura un
trader de matière première condamnée
pour pollution en Afrique
les Européens ont une idée
minière
les gens imaginent encore des mineurs
avec des lampes frontales que c'est un
travail physique
un travail risqué
nous produisons les composants chimiques
pour les batteries du sulfate de nickel
et du sulfate de cobalt nous le
produisons à partir des matières
premières que nous extrions nous-mêmes
il y a l'extraction la bioxiviation et
enfin la production des produits
chimiques pour les batteries
[Musique]
militant écologiste Mika Floyd a enquêté
sur la catastrophe de 2012
révoltée par la négligence des anciens
propriétaires de la mine il fait partie
des activistes qui ont réclamé sa
fermeture
affamée à l'époque on l'appelait mine de
Tal Vivara
ils nous ont dit qu'il ferait de la
biolexiviation et que ce serait la mine
la plus respectueuse de l'environnement
dans le monde
ils ont dit qu'ils ne rejetteraient pas
d'eau usée tout ça mais c'était juste un
discours marketing à destination des
politiciens et des habitants c'est pour
ça qu'ils ont soutenu cette énorme
projet minier
la première chose que nous avons fait
c'est de construire un centre de
traitement des eaux usées nous avons
utilisé les meilleures technologies
disponibles
ce centre de traitement des eaux est
relié à un pipeline qui permet de
rejeter les eaux traités vers les grands
cours d'eau
et du coup lorsqu'il y a de grosses
pluies cela ne perturbe pas notre
production
nous purifions l'eau avant de la
rejeteriation qui est une technologie
dans laquelle ils avaient investi dans
le but de l'utiliser sur ce site ne
fonctionnait pas encore de manière
correcte à leur époque
nous l'avons énormément développé et
elle fonctionne de manière stable
aujourd'hui
mais l'idée de base reste la même
Mika Floyd se méfie du discours de
l'industrie tout comme Yarin à tunnel
geochimiste et président de
l'association mining watch Finland
ensemble il surveille les abords de la
mine exploités par terrafamé
taux de nickel dépassent toujours la
norme de qualité environnementale et il
y a toutes les chances que ce soit
pareil pour le cadmium les rejets sont
bien au-dessus des seuils
la présence de métaux lourds est
confirmée par des analyses officielles
connues de terrafamés la société
reconnaît qu'une fuite a bien eu lieu en
2020 pollution qu'elle dit avoir résolu
quant aux concentration relevée
aujourd'hui par Yarin est une naine
terrafamé estime qu'à son origine
naturelle le biochimiste reste sceptique
un tuyau de traitement d'eau peut
toujours céder et des déchets miniers
peuvent encore se répandre dans le sol
tu vois le plus gros problème de cette
mine je veux dire la roche stérile ou la
gang
contient 9% de soufre
réagit avec l'eau et l'air et cette
réaction du soufre avec l'eau et l'air
pour une tonne de roche stérile
cela donne 300 kg d'acide sulfurique
concentré
pendant des milliers d'années tant qu'il
reste de la roche stérile des partisans
de la mine nous accuse du syndrome Nimbi
note in my backyard
j'aimerais bien leur demander de me
présenter quelqu'un qui veut dans son
arrière cours 300 kilos de ses déchets
nocifs qui détruisent et polluent
l'environnement c'est tout simplement
illégal et inadmissible tout à fait
et au nickel et bien il faut savoir
qu'ici on génère chaque année
50 tonnes de ces décès dangereux pour
produire le nickel nécessaire à une
batterie de voiture électrique
tu imagines
pour le nickel d'une seule batterie
alors on peut se demander qu'est-ce que
dirait les adeptes de la voiture
électrique si on la leur livrer avec
tous ces déchets dangereux
malgré les alertes des écologistes
l'état finlandais maintient l'activité
de terrafamé pourtant la société
finlandaise ne pourra équiper en
batterie que 300000 véhicules
électriques par an face au 30 millions
prévus sur les routes d'ici 2030 rien
que pour le cobalt il faudrait 10
projets comme therapamé pour y parvenir
l'Europe ne sera jamais un eldorado du
cobalt il y a un secteur où elle peut en
revanche peser
le recyclage il pourrait fournir jusqu'à
10% du cobalt mondial d'ici 10 ans la
société Umicore naît de l'ancienne Union
minière belge est pionnière sur ce
marché elle affirme pouvoir recycler à
terme la quasi-totalité du cobalt des
batteries
nous avons commencé par le recyclage des
batteries de téléphone portable en
sachant que l'arrivée des batteries de
voiture n'est qu'une question de temps
ce recyclage existe en complément de
l'exploitation minière dont nous avons
encore besoin aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
comme le cobaye cela
[Musique]
dès 2035 les batteries de toutes les
voitures électriques en vente dans
l'Union européenne devrait contenir au
moins 20% de cobalt recyclées
Volkswagen a lancé une usine
spécialement dédiée tandis que les
futurs poids lourds européens de la
production de batterie comme Vercors en
France ou North volt en Suède ont
intégré cette donne dès le lancement de
leur giga usine
pour nos batteries sont naturellement
recyclables et elles sont recyclables
encore et encore en fait on les extrait
une fois et on peut les utiliser pour
toujours c'est une donnée fondamentale
étant donné la vitesse à laquelle le
marché se développe ça va prendre
quelques décennies cela va donc encore
prendre du temps avant d'arriver à un
marché ou une voiture qui entre remplace
une voiture qui sort mais une fois que
vous y êtes vous obtenez un
approvisionnement circulaire en matière
première
cela veut dire qu'au fil du temps grâce
à ce cycle de recyclage les pays seront
moins dépendants à l'égard des minerais
africains
à la suite du rapport d'Amnesty
internationale de 2016 les acteurs du
secteur minier ont été contraints
d'assainir leur chaîne
d'approvisionnement
lors d'un forum spécial à colwezi en
l'Organisation de coopération et de
développement économique l'OCDE a réuni
les entreprises minières pour les aider
à mieux tracer leur cobalt
sa solution le devoir de diligence
raisonnable
la diligence raisonnable est un
processus par lequel les sociétés sont
amenées à cartographier leur chaîne
d'approvisionnement
comme leur relation commerciale et
opérationnelle
cela permet d'identifier si ces
relations commerciales ou ces chaînes
d'approvisionnement
violent les droits humains
et de quelle manière
la diligence raisonnable cherche
également à réduire ses risques métier
les entreprises ont différentes
tactiques dans ce soustraire à leur
responsabilité
consiste à engager des consultants pour
réaliser les enquêtes
ce sont des cabinets très chers qui
prennent la responsabilité de la
diligence raisonnable
bien sûr ils sont dissociés
l'autre tactique c'est d'adhérer à des
programmes sectoriels il s'associe aux
autres entreprises du secteur et il crée
une entité qui fait le travail pour eux
ou bien ils font la promotion de normes
auxquelles ils adèrent tous
c'est juste une signature ils peuvent
dire oui nous sommes d'accord avec ces
normes on a signé mais ça ne permet pas
forcément de changer les choses sur le
terrain
le travail des enfants a accaparé
l'attention
à juste titre
il en reste encore des milliers sur les
sites artisanaux du loup à la barre
mais de nombreuses ONG estiment que ce
phénomène à occulter d'autres problèmes
provoqués par les mines industriels que
le devoir de diligence peine à
contrecarrer
les déplacements forcés de population
sans compensation correcte la pollution
et enfin la corruption
le pillage des ressources minières
congolaises ne date pas d'hier
durant plus de 60 ans la Belgique
coloniale en attiré une richessement
après l'indépendance du Congo en 1960
une nouvelle forme de prédation
s'installe
le dictateur Mobutu et ses proches ont
puisé des milliards dans les coffres de
la Gécamine l'entreprise minière d'Etat
lorsque Laurent Désiré Kabila renverse
Mobutu en 1997 le pays en faillite
replonge dans la guerre
après son assassinat c'est son fils
Joseph Kabila qui lui succède
il rétablit la paix et relance le
secteur minier pour remplir les caisses
de l'état
mais là j'ai Camille est en ruine
en 2002
on a constaté tout ce que la germine
était tombée en faillite comme derrière
l'État congolais était tombé aussi
économiques et sur d'autres plans et la
Banque mondiale a initié ou à conseiller
à l'État congolais défaire des réformes
parce qu'on a dit vous avez les minerais
mais vous avez pas les moyens de rendre
les secteur fiables il faut vous ouvrir
aux multinationales
les opérateurs miniers qui sont venus
donc les multinationales qui sont venus
au Congo c'est c'est glenkor c'est
surface quantum c'est tous les grands
qui sont venus ici
ils sont pas venus pour le développement
des populations ils sont venus pour
faire les affaires
[Musique]
alors pour comprendre le secteur du
cobalt aujourd'hui il faut remonter en
arrière il faut regarder comment les
entreprises qui sont là aujourd'hui
comment ils ont acquis les concessions
minières notamment les concessions de
cobalt et là ce qu'on voit c'est que il
y a eu un rôle vraiment déterminant
crucial d'un homme d'affaires israélien
qui s'appelle danger claire qui en fait
a joué un peu le rôle d'intermédiaire
entre les multinationales qui
cherchaient ses concessions riches en
cuivre et en cobalt d'une part et de
l'autre côté les politiciens congolais
qui avaient quelque part le pouvoir de
décision sur l'octroi de ses concessions
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé l'entreprise
de l'État a plutôt fait des contrats ce
qu'on appelle de gré à gré donc des
contrats directement avec cet homme
d'affaires israélien très connecté à
Joseph kabilier très proche à
l'ex-président de la RDC et a vendu ses
concessions à très bas prix
[Musique]
dès sa prise de pouvoir en 2001 Joseph
Kabila fait de Dan Gertler son homme de
confiance
arrivé au Congo avec de l'argent frais à
un moment où le pays en manquait
cruellement Gertler devient le sésame
des entreprises occidentales pour
accéder à Kabila
en 2016 le leader mondial de négoce de
matière première Glencore fait appel à
lui afin d'acquérir les meilleurs
gisements ils deviennent co actionnaires
de moutons d'un mining la plus grande
mine de cobalt du monde
Glenn corps va aussi avancer des
millions de dollars à Gertler en échange
de son intervention auprès de Kinshasa
pour un autre contrat minier
une fois révélé dans la presse cette
transaction attire l'attention des
autorités américaines
elle soupçonne l'homme d'affaires
d'avoir corrompu le régime Kabila dans
de nombreux projets dont certains
impliquent même un fond d'investissement
américain
au total les ONG estiment que l'État
congolais aurait perdu plus de 1
milliard de dollars dans ces
transactions
les ennuis commencent alors pour Geert
la conséquence c'est qu'il a été placé
sous sanction
lui et d'autres responsables de hauts
responsables du régime Kabila et
d'autres aussi
mais il est resté la cible la plus
importante du fait de la valeur des
actifs qu'il contrôlait
pour revenir dans le jeu congolais les
États-Unis vissent Dan Gertler afin de
pousser Kabila vers la sortie il
poursuivent également Glenn corps qui
fait aussi l'objet d'une enquête au
Royaume-Uni et en Suisse
en 2022 Glencore a annoncé provisionné
un milliard et demi de dollars pour
régler ses affaires avec la justice
comment se positionne alors des
industriels comme une mycor qui
s'approvisionne en cobalt auprès du
géant suisse
nous devrons apprécier la situation et
faire notre propre évaluation
si un juge estime qu'une des parties est
coupable nous nous pencherons sur
l'affaire et prendront une décision
en fonction de l'issue juridique
pour nous c'est assez décevant parce que
c'est comme c'est comme si vous dites
une entreprise qui exploite le minerai
ou qui achète qui achète du minerai
artisanal qui a été fait avec le travail
dans l'enfant sur le site vous dites oui
mais en fait l'entreprise n'a pas été
condamnée pour avoir utilisé des enfants
et donc il y a pas de problème vous
voyez un peu donc c'est un peu dans
cette situation que pour le travail
d'enfant dans les mines on utiliserait
jamais cet argument ils n'ont pas été
condamnés et donc il y a pas de problème
apparemment pour la corruption tant
qu'on n'est pas condamné il y a pas de
problème et des script il est clair que
pour nous la corruption n'est pas un
crime sans victime on la déteint trop
souvent comme cela juste de l'argent qui
change de main entre des intermédiaires
et de haut fonctionnaires corrompus mais
au bout de la chaîne c'est le citoyen
ordinaire qui souffre de cette
corruption et de manière très violente
et cela a été le cas avec la mine de
metal coach
la mine de métal colle est constituée
par des rejets miniers de coluésie
entassés sur des kilomètres lors de
l'exploitation coloniale belge ils sont
en fait un des sites les plus juteux de
la Cooper belt
au début des années 2000 la société
canadienne First Quantum en obtient les
droits d'exploitation c'est l'affaire du
siècle
ces résidus contiendrait encore 300000
tonnes de cobalt cela fait du cobalt
pour une valeur de 20 milliards de
dollars mais soudainement le régime
Kabila retire la licence minière à faire
ce contour
les pièces et les dossiers du tribunal
nous montrent ce qu'il s'est passé et ce
qu'il s'est passé c'est que le précédent
permis d'exploitation a été annulé sous
l'influence d'une société appartenant à
danger il avait vu que c'était une mine
très rentable il l'a ensuite récupéré
pour une courte période pour la céder
ensuite à une société minière
multinationale qui s'appelait you raise
and Natural Resort
de la mine aujourd'hui
mais les documents judiciaires nous
permettent de savoir que cela a été
possible du fait d'une opération de
corruption menée par danger claire
auprès d'officiel congolais parmi
lesquels des juges
le groupe Casaq région resource group
via sa filiale metalcool fini la
construction de l'usine et exploite le
site
malgré les engagements de métal col les
700 employés licenciés par first contum
ne seront ni réembauchés ni indemnisés
comme le projet de métacol ça devait
décès c'est un projet qui n'est pas
assez éthique pour nous voilà pourquoi
nous avons voulu faire un recours
judiciaire
c'est un appel à la conscience
collective c'est-à-dire de toutes les
premières parties prenantes aux
consommateurs finaux
internationales aux multinationales de
comprendre que
on ne peut pas se contenter de consommer
d'exploiter de consommer les cobalt sans
regarder les trains de vie des
populations qui participent à
l'extraction des séminaires là
j'espère qu'à travers cette cause à
travers cet engagement nous aurons
sensibilisé tous les autres partisans
sur les vrais problèmes qui gagne le
secteurs du puret du cobalt plutôt que
se focaliser sur la question de l'enfant
dans les mines je n'ai pas que c'est un
problème mais ce n'est pas le plus grand
problème du secteur
on avait accès aux soins médicaux
on gagnait le salaire pour payer pour le
scolariser les enfants mais d'un coup là
quand il y a eu de travail des travaux
et ma fille a souffert quand elle a
souffert alors j'ai fait par tous les
moyens pour aller à l'hôpital là on
s'est soignait là on a refusé vous
n'avez pas droit de devenir ici alors en
coupe de route la succombé
et les garçons même après une année
de la maladie de la malaria
il est là
oui
la fièvre jaune
il est décédé aussi
j'avais 8 ans
bienvenue effectivement dans notre
programme de la Radio Télévision manuka
on va parler écosystème quel impact de
l'extraction minière sur la population
environnante et donc on a reçu le
professeur bonzack toxicologue et
professeur à l'Université de magie
professeur dites-nous d'abord à quoi
consister votre mission ici à collisi
nous avons commencé au départ par
évaluer par l'évaluation de niveau de
contamination des écosystèmes des
populations c'est à dire et quels sont
les niveaux de contamination de cours
d'eau au niveau de contamination des
poissons qui sont consommés justement et
donc qui sont dans les cours d'eau qui
sont contaminés et qui affectent aussi
les consommateurs les niveaux de
contamination humaine à partir de la
consommation de poissons à partir de
l'inallation de la nation des poussières
et à partir de de la contamination de
l'environnement dans lequel nous sommes
en train de vivre
le professeur Célestin bandza en quête
depuis 15 ans aux côtés des ONG pour
dénoncer l'impact environnemental et
sanitaire de l'exploitation minière au
Congo
un domaine où les entreprises pollueuses
appliquent une diligence raisonnable
bien incomplète
alors c'est à partir d'ici que les
acides ont coulé jusque là en bas vers
la rivière lune quelle est l'entreprise
qui est à la base de
ces astres écologique c'est d'abord
l'entreprise qui appartient à Glencore
cette mousse ici c'est la chou
quand il voit que le bassin est plein
ils ouvrent cette canalisation c'est ce
qui cause le changement de la couleur
d'eau mais aussi de la mousse qui
provient de la chaux qui sont en train
de verser dans le dans le bassin
quand il met de la de la peau diminuer
l'acidité et maintenir le pH au-dessus
de 7 mais je ne pense pas qu'ils aient
résolu la le problème parce que les
méthodes toxiques et l'acide persiste
vous voyez la laspect de l'eau et même
les sols les bouts de sédimentation donc
c'est la couleur la couleur montre que
il y a encore un problème très sérieux
de pollution et donc c'est le problème
il est très très important d'autant plus
que cette rivière se déverse dans dans
le fleuve Congo c'est l'un des fleuves
les plus importants de l'Afrique il
alimente pratiquement une grande partie
de de notre pays
sous la pression des ONG Glencore a
finalement reconnu les fuites d'acide
sulfurique mais elle a démenti tout
impact sur les étangs alentours
paradoxalement l'entreprise a commencé à
indemniser des victimes et à entamer la
réhabilitation des bassins piscicoles
le professeur Banza et son équipe ont
démontré en 2018 des taux de cobalt très
élevés dans le sang et les urines des
creuseurs de colwezi leur article publié
par le prestigieux groupe nature a
montré des modifications de l'ADN des
enfants exposée aux poussières de
minerais un indice de risque élevé de
cancer pour l'avenir
aujourd'hui il effectue des tests sur
une centaine de creuseurs dans les puits
ils sont exposés à duradon un gaz
radioactif et cancérigène émis depuis
l’uranium présent dans la roche
courage courage
correctement et
la pollution telle que c'est fait
actuellement ça sera un problème ça sera
un problème parce que les rivières sont
pratiquement détruites la plupart des
rivières de la province du Grand Katanga
par exemple ton violon Katanga sont déjà
affectés par la pollution et pas
seulement ici au Katanga nous avons vu
ça qui vous la même chose et presque
attractes à travers tous les pays là où
il y a l'extension des ressources
minérales il y a ce problème là et donc
c'est vraiment si on fait pas attention
et le pays risque d'être un scandale à
la fois écologique et toxicologique
[Musique]
IX qui a succédé à Kabila en 2018 il
avait promis la renégociation des
contrats miniers mais le processus
s'éternise et la population ne bénéficie
toujours pas des richesses de son propre
pays
[Musique]
en attendant les minerais congolais et
ceux du monde entier vont continuer à
nourrir les centaines de millions de
voitures électriques prévues sur nos
routes
[Musique]
mais partout sur la planète des voies
s'élèvent
activistes avocats scientifiques en
quête et s'organisent face à l'industrie
minière
le monde politique ne peut plus ignorer
leurs paroles
[Musique]
voilà pour cette enquête signée quand un
noir Falisse et Arnaud zeitman c'est la
fin de ce magazine merci de l'avoir
suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
reporter sur France 24
[Musique]